Hey everyone, we're gonna be looking at ...
price ceilings and price floors.
And these are two additional ways that governments can ...
come into markets and create distortions that destroy wealth.
Now what are these?
We're gonna look at these each in turn.
And we're gonna start by looking at our price ceilings.
So price ceilings here, originally we're in this market,
everything is great.
People are voluntarily transacting for tacos at $4 each.
And there is no incentive for anybody to deviate from their ...
current behavior.
But we're going to introduce this new law.
Maximum price for tacos equals $2.
This is a price ceiling because it's setting a ...
maximum price that can be charged for the tacos that are being sold.
Now this sounds probably pretty good, right?
It sounds great for consumers because,
hey, we can't be charged any ...
more than $2 for those tacos.
But what about the producers?
Producers now can't charge more than $2.
They used to charge $4.
And so a lot of the producers inside the market are,
might exit simply because they can't produce tacos at $2.
It requires a significantly higher price to cover their ...
production cost.
So we have this new law going into effect and what ...
we're going to be doing here is looking at some different ...
scenarios with this price ceiling.
Now these taco sellers are very happy.
Their taco prices are already $2.
And a new maximum price of $2 doesn't really affect their ...
business at all.
What we see is any price ceiling above the market price ...
is non binding.
In this case, it's at the market price.
So we're just going to charge what the market determines and that's $2.
So price ceilings have to be set below what the market ...
price happens to be.
They can't be set above when they are set below what the ...
market price is, look what happens.
We have way too many people wanting these tacos ...
when the market price was $4.
Now the market price is maxed at $2.
We have way too many people wanting these tacos.
So our quantity demand is greater than our quantity ...
supplied and that creates a shortage.
You can see there, there's one taco left,
but there's a lot of people who look panicked and ...
worried that they're not going to get any tacos because ...
they're so cheap.
And they should be binding price ceilings.
Ones that are set below the market equilibrium create shortages.
So if the market equilibrium price is $4 and the price ...
being charged is $2, you've created a binding price ceiling.
If that price ceiling happened to be $6 instead of $4.
Then we would just revert to the market equilibrium ...
because that's where the conditions clear themselves.
That is quantity demand equals quantity supplied.
So in this case, what we see here is a binding ...
price ceiling simply because our quantity demand ...
outstrips our quantity supplied because the price is ...
lower than what the market equilibrium price happens to be.
So let's look at what we have here.
At a price of $4, we can clearly see that we ...
get have a market equilibrium.
Anything below that, we are going to have a ...
binding price ceiling.
Here at a price of $2, I have it highlighted.
Our quantity demand is 90.
Our quantity supplied is 50.
This creates excess demand of 40.
We also call that a shortage because more people want to ...
consume it than what producers are willing and ...
able to supply.
So we see here that we're kicking out some of the not ...
kicking them out, they just can't get it because ...
producers aren't willing and able to sell as much as they need to.
So price ceilings are distorting markets and they're ...
going to do a lot of other things as well.
And we're going to hit that a little bit later on.
So here we have a binding price ceiling there at the $4.
That's non binding.
All right, now let's look at price floors.
Now we have a new law that says minimum price for tacos is $6.
Well, that sounds pretty good if ...
you're a producer right now you have to sell for $6 and ...
customers have to accept that.
But wait, what if customers don't want ...
that because the price is now higher than what it used to be?
All right, so let's see what happens.
Well, in this case, guess what?
Taco prices were always $6, so no big deal.
In this case we have a price floor that is non binding.
Any price floor at or below market price is non binding ...
because all we'll do is just revert to the equilibrium.
Had the price floor been $4, we just would have reverted ...
to the $6 market price.
All right, now what happens if the ...
market price is actually $4, but the new law says tacos have to be $6.
In this case, she has a lot of tacos that ...
she's not selling.
She's overproduced.
Quantity supplied is greater than the quantity demand.
You see the people in the background leaving,
they don't want to pay the $6 for those tacos.
So we have a surplus because our quantity ...
supplied is greater than our quantity demand.
But this creates a binding price floor.
Binding price floors only work when they're set above the ...
market equilibrium price.
Otherwise people just revert to what the market happens to be.
So in this case, let's find our equilibrium there.
$4.70 and 70 quantity demand,
quantity supplied.
If we have a $6 market price, look what happens.
$6 market price.
What we're going to see is a binding price floor because ...
it's set above the market equilibrium price of $4.
In this case, our excess supply is equal to 40.
We have a surplus of 40 tacos on the bottom here at ...
$2 we have a non binding price floor.
And that's because people are just going to revert to the ...
market equilibrium because that's where quantity demand ...
and quantity supplied are equal to each other.
And it's just easier to get rid of that excess demand that's ...
built up there.
Producers will just move up to the $4 because again,
the price for us is I can't charge any price below $2,
but I can charge above it.
And so if our producers want to clear that shortage,
they just raise the price to $4.
And that's where market equilibrium is established.
So let's look at these two together.
Price ceiling versus price floor.
For one to be binding, it has to be set below the ...
market equilibrium price.
For the other to be buying, it has to be set above the ...
One creates a shortage, the other creates a surplus.
And you can see how quantity demand and ...
quantity supplied are played in there.
Price ceilings induce rationing in black markets,
lowers product quality and reduces profits.
Here the famous example is rent control.
Rent control is a price ceiling.
What happens is you create different types of scenarios.
The landlords create different types of programs or whatever.
They reduce their maintenance,
they raise application fees, things like that,
to recoup the market price of what they were trying to get.
Price floors reduce access to items.
It can encourage waste.  We saw what happened.
We were overproducing.
If you're looking at the minimum wage market,
it could actually cause unemployment.
So we can see there are a lot of wealth destroying ...
properties behind price ceilings and price floors.
So what we want to keep in mind is that we started by ...
looking at voluntary transactions to generate ...
surplus in wealth inside of an economy.
We found that when that happens,
we can maximize the amount of surplus that we have.
However, as we've introduced taxes ...
and subsidies in another video and price ceilings and ...
price floors in this video, what we have found is that ...
these kind of policies actually distort wealth and they ...
destroy wealth.
So when we have these types of policies introduced into the ...
market, what we want to do is ensure ...
that we understand them and how to use them to create ...
more wealth for ourselves.
Even though these things are designed to destroy wealth.
And that's all. Hope you've enjoyed it.